So in fact, let's, let's go there, let's, let's go to use case number two,
which was the having to do with the containment vessel was not ready.
So our first use case asks the question, but
the question might come out negative and
in that case we have like a contingency we have to, have to deal with.
So this is a variant on the, on the first use case.
So, in order to get there,
the, the steps are that the query is sent to the containment vessel.
If it is not ready then a message must be sent to the hot water source,
telling it to stop or prevent the flow of water.
Now what's, what's going on here is, really a couple things.
One is, the startup situation where, before we even start.
The, we check whether the, the pot is there, but
it could also be the case that somebody pulls that pot out too quickly, okay?
And so in that case it's not going to be ready either.
In both of those situations we want to make sure that
water doesn't start pouring through.
We can extrapolate it and
indicate that when the containment vessel is returned to the, the heating plate.
Another message is sent to the hot water source, enabling it to resume.
So we're talking about one to turn, turn off the hot water source and
the other one to turn it back on.